X it's a pleasure to be here my title
the title of my talk is online
advertisements and online algorithms
online on an addressing this is what we
have been talking all day so you all
should know pretty much what this is
about so search ads display ads as you
see on facebook skype New York Times
eyes on your mobile phone second part of
my title is online algorithms chase a
textbook written on online algorithms in
1998 this faceless evil looking guy here
I supposed to be the adversary who's
making life difficult for this guy
walking a tightrope balancing something
on his hand this this is algorithm and
if you see the table of contents of this
textbook it has problems with names such
as these the t's do not have anything to
do with online ads right so what's up
what this area studies is decision
making under uncertainty and that is
very relevant to online ads and what
I'll talk today is a modern version of
this online algorithms how this area was
influenced online algorithms how this
area was influenced by online
advertising and how it influenced back
the practice of all the night
the story begins in 2007 really with
this paper by ionic method which I was
it only a means of erient who me she was
running and I think it it began with
amines Google interview where someone
asked him this question I think Elena
can connect correct me if I'm wrong and
was motivated by budget management in
search ads and an important thing that
this paper did was they greatly
simplified this problem so this actual
problem has so many bells and whistles
it's hard to wrap your head around and
they took out a very clean version of
the problem for instance all the game
theoretic aspects were removed and they
converted it into a pure optimization
problem here is a problem that they
studied sir n advertisers and each a
dresser begins a day with some budget
and queries come one by one during the
day whenever you get a query I you see
the bits of the addresses for that query
and you have to allocate this to one of
the advertisers to allocate I to a then
you collect BIA from his budget so as a
deep progresses with budget depletes and
once a budget of the address it is spend
you cannot collect any more money from
him so you want to maximize a total
revenue which is a total you know for
every address dedicate how much you
allocate it to him you collect all of
that but not more than expulsion
why not allocate each query to the
highest bidder be done within why is
there a need for an algorithm at all
it's not very hard to see that if you
did this you could get only fifty
percent of what you could and got if you
did something else so there's an easy
example that choices and in fact the
greedy algorithm always gets at least
fifty percent of the optimum that you
could have got if you knew everything
ahead of time and this paper gave a very
beautiful algorithm and very natural
algorithm called the balance algorithm
which are very elegant alliances what
the algorithm does is this is not then
what the algorithm does is it balances
the bid and the remaining budget using a
discount factor and it assigns the query
to the highest discounted bidder the
discount is calculated as a function of
the unspent fraction of the budget at
that time for that day sir using this
formula so what is this form light it's
e to the minus X it looks like this so
think of this alpha when you start the
unspent fraction is one so you start at
1 over e and as you deplete your budget
and your unspent fraction goes to 0 it
goes all the way up to 1 and so this the
discount factor is this it's now you
think of it as you start here when you
start the discount factor is high so
your bid is literally high so your favor
you start at 1-1 ovary and by the time
your budget is exhausted this discount
factor has gone to zero so once your
budget is exhausted your bid is zero so
you're not getting any more queries so
it is a very nice natural algorithm and
they showed a worst-case performance
guarantee so this is with no assumption
on the input and what they showed is
that you always get at least a 1 minus 1
over e fraction of whatever else you
could have got if you knew everything
ahead of time this is about sixty-three
percent so really got half they get
sixty percent to it so it's an
improvement and this is
the competitive ratio and moreover this
is tight so there is no algorithm that
gets anything better terms of
Confederation they did make one
assumption that the only assumption they
made was a bit to budget ratio small so
each bid was relatively small compared
to the total budget of our place and
this is a reasonable assumption in the
example of such times for instance so
this is a very nice story you know you
have a natural problem and you have the
optimal algorithm for it so it is very
beautiful and this started the whole
area of this online algorithms and the
only night race
around the same time there was
essentially the same algorithm was given
by a book pinder common Jane who's here
and now or it was the same algorithm the
difference was they gave a primal dual
interpretation of this algorithm so here
is an LP relaxation for the problem and
here it is a stool don't be intimidated
by all these equations I just wanted to
focus on the duel and these constraints
in the duel so there are variables for
every query beta is a variable for the
query and there are variables for every
advertiser so these are alpha s and
there is a constraint for every pair and
it looks like this let me rewrite it you
know that makes it easier to follow and
let me focus let me fix an eye and look
at this constraint for all a so it looks
like this essentially what it says is
the beta Amos we at least some maximum
or all I Otis's this bia time for mazhar
fee and we are trying to minimize beta I
so you might as well set bet I to be
equal to this if you were solving this
tool and this should look familiar to
the algorithm that i just showed the
previous slide in fact the algorithms
allocation ruin comes from the
complimentary slackness conditions of
the selfie optimality slackers condition
says if x is bigger than 0 so now X I a
is an indicator variable whether you
allocate I to a or not so if you
allocated I to a in the optimal solution
and beta I must be equal to this and
since this was a bit i was a maximum the
a that you allocated must be the ARB max
and this is where this allocation rule
comes from and so there is a reason why
i wrote the previous algorithm in this
way and because i had the benefit of
foresight so this this shows what
foresight can buy you
so it's essentially the same algorithm
the same formula to set the dual
variables the analysis is different it
is a primal dual analysis so you just we
know whenever you get something in the
revenue you just charge it to the duel
with a factor of one masanori and that
shows you this this is the one-minus-one
already competitive algorithm it's a
very nice proof so you know once again
we have these two papers you solve this
problem solved in a very nice way very
natural algorithm nice analysis the
previous setup was dynamic right you
have to allocate items as they come yeah
this where's the dynamics here so this
is the setup is the same it's the same
problem and the algorithm is the same
this is a motivation for the algorithm
and this is this it connects algorithm
to the duel so you change the duel as
you go along and use a duel to do the
allocation online and whenever the
analysis says okay you know in every
step what is the increase in the the
primal object if nadal rhythm got and
the duel also you can show it always
increases and just you know sure that
you store between ratio of one is gonna
be as if you know so you don't have to
UM not it's I don't have to know
everything ahead of time so for instance
I don't have to I only said the beta I
variables only when I comes until then I
don't have to I'm not solving this LP at
once I'm also solving the LP online
okay thanks so you know we have this
nice algorithm and entered said so what
do you do next so the thing is the real
world instances are not really they do
not look like the instances that induce
this 1-1 every ratio so there is there
are set of instances that you know for
snow algorithm can get better than one a
story so real value instances do not
look like that and because of that
people started thinking of okay what
else can we do how can we show how can
we capture what real world instances
look like and they turn to stochastic
models so for instance you can assume
that the input comes from some
distribution but algorithm does not know
this distribution here is an example it
is called the iid model so there is some
distribution over what any one query can
look like and every step you get ID
sample from this distribution another
example is the random order model here
an adversary still picks all the set of
theories ahead of time and then nature
shuffles Aquarius in a random order
uniformly at random and the order in
which they get is a shuffled order so
the algorithm is sees the queries in a
random order
well in my paper with Tom Hayes we gave
this algorithm that works well in such a
model of you know such a stochastic
model what it does is it takes a first
epsilon fraction of the queries and uses
this as training data and what you
trained you learn the optimal duels on
this sample okay so you can solve the LP
now the duel will be restricted to the
sample you find the dual variables and
just use those tools to allocate for the
rest of the time so using the same
discounted highest discounted better
rule and the nice thing that we showed
was that now the competitive ratio tends
to 1 as the bid to budget ratio tends to
0 so in particular you get one as
epsilon competitive ratio if the bit to
budget ratio is something like epsilon
cube by n log n so the difference from
the worst case is now we do not get
stuck at this oneness memory and there
is some benign assumption about the
input can actually get close to optimal
so any algorithm that gets this kind of
a thing that computation tends to 1 as
some parameter tends to something we
call it as if vertically optimal
algorithms so you can approach no the
optimal allocation even without knowing
what's going to come
you can do better why just train this
once in the beginning you can retrain as
you get more samples so this is standard
doubling trick so every time now you use
these samples you train the duel on
these use it for the allocation for
these queries now you use the duel for
everything from the beginning to here
for the next set of queries and then you
use everything from here to here for the
next set and this shaves off factor of
epsilon in the convergence rate so now
get epsilon squared by n log n as shown
by a global bank and E but actually what
was more important about this as was
shown in these two papers is this
technique you can use it to solve a wide
class of what are called packing
problems and not just the particular
problem that i showed in the beginning
and one particular problem in this class
is very closely related to the display
and problem so we're going to take a
detour now and go into the displayed
from this is very similar to the problem
that i showed before the main difference
is instead of budget constraints you now
have capacity constraints so every
advertiser has a certain number CA and
you can only get credit for a CA of
these impressions that you assigned to
him and the rest is the same so the
impressions now either called
impressions they come online you know we
have to allocate to one of them as soon
as account it's a very similar problem
and now the difference actually here is
this is very close to the actual problem
in display ads that a publisher has to
solve so the weight starts work you know
a majority of that the majority revenue
actually comes from this guaranteed
delivery where the publisher has made
some contracts with advertisers about
you know assigning him a certain number
of impressions of a certain type we're
using all the targeting that president
talked about within a certain timeframe
and now he has made this contracts
already now he has to deliver on this so
he was getting impressions online and he
has all these contracts is signed and
his summon you know he's trying to
maximize his
kind of value from these contracts and
now there is no game theory in this
problem so this problem is actually very
close to the actual problem that the
this lad you know system has to solve
and the same duel base allocation idea
for the sarcastic model you know just
learn the duels from the sample works so
the allocation true look slightly
different here it is an additive factor
instead of a multiplicative factor but
essentially see my dev works you get
similar guarantees and and you know you
get similar giantess in the stochastic
model but you know in the worst case of
guarantee so much was having guarantees
it would be like you have a certain
reach that you have to achieve I feel
like that inequality should go the other
way like no it's actually an equality oh
yeah yeah and also it was at this point
that people started really paying
attention to these techniques of using
the duels and learning the doors from
the history and trying to apply to the
distal add problems now so this was
around the time when I had personally I
had joined Microsoft and you know had
this results and I was very confident
that okay look you know we have solved
this problem let's just go tell this
guy's what to do and you know it will be
great and then this happened
so so actually what happened was not
that bad you know we tried out dis
algorithms they worked reasonably well
but they didn't do better than whatever
algorithm they had which was I really
don't know what I'll get had because it
was built over here so you know a lot of
all kinds of hack all kind of spaghetti
code was there actually you know nobody
understood what is has instead and okay
so that turned out to be a plus point
actually because at least our algorithm
we could understand what they did and
you know later it turned out to be
really crucial but we had to go back to
the drawing board and I said okay what's
what is happening so the algorithm is
not reactive enough even with this
doubling trick it's very hard to solve
this big LPS you know very fast so the
algorithm was slow to react to changes
in the input and the assumption that we
made for instance that the distribution
is stationary put the ID and the random
order models are essentially the same
assumption this is not true there are
seasonality is that our weekly monthly
yearly you know seasonality is that was
not captured here by the way the title
of this slide is a pun it refers to two
things one it refers to the process we
went through in you know having a model
and algorithms going talking to the
engineers and then seeing what the
algorithm did come back redesign so we
did a couple of iterations of this I am
skipping the iterations and directly
going to the final algorithm that we
shipped but it also refers to the
algorithm that we designed eventually
which is continuously update these duels
so the rules are learning continuously
and as a result you know we could show
that they converge faster and they're
better able to adapt to changes in the
input distribution
the dual update rule is really simple
this is a simplified version that we
used in practice the actual you know
things about which we prove theorems is
slightly more complicated but it is the
same in spirit what it tries to do is it
tries to keep the spin along a straight
line you know starting you should start
from zero you should go to your budget
in a straight line as time progresses
and it tries to adjust it so what is
this doing so in any one time period if
you spend more than this ideal rate it
increases your alpha if you go back to
the formula this decreases your
effective build so you get less in the
future because you got more now and vice
versa if you got less now this makes you
get more in the future so it's intuitive
but it took some work to show that this
actually works and it works better than
before we shared off this factor of n
from the internal matter which is a big
deal so we got this convergence state of
epsilon squared x log n which is also
the optimal convergence rate under this
assumption you just use the celerity
some search for this result so this yeah
so I'll tell you so this is for a priori
this is for ID so I that's exactly my
next slide you also see is a model to
take care of the season allottees and we
call it a twist Syria stochastic input
may not be the best name um come of it
and what we allow is a different
distribution in each time step so excess
charge this might look too strong right
this is as bad as worst case so we have
to make some restrictions and we make
one of two kinds of restrictions so
first equation for the first restriction
is that all the distributions are benign
which means that the optimum value if
you had used this distribution
throughout should be high enough so this
is our notion of a benign distribution
and as long as the dt was benign you can
change arbitrarily in each time step so
that's the first assumption under which
this works the second assumption is that
we know something
about these distributions so in
particular we know the expected
consumption rate so think of you know if
an optimum algorithm knew everything and
try to allocate optimally what would be
the expectation consumption expected
consumption for every address or
overtime so the better you know estimate
you have of this a better your algorithm
is going to be and this can be estimated
also from historic data so if you look
at the historic data if you look at the
seasonality is can project it in you can
try to solve big LPS and get some
estimate of this and so the special case
of the society when the distributions do
not change but this is what really is is
really useful so we went back to the
engineers and this time the algorithm
work it worked really well it worked
much better than any other algorithm and
it was simple so they could understand
the algorithm they could they knew what
the algorithm is supposed to do so when
the algorithm did something funny they
caught it and there would be a bug most
of the time so and then they could also
fine-tune they could make tweaks and
could fine-tune to take care of all
kinds of corner cases not caught by the
theory and in short they loved it and it
was used at Microsoft for a few years to
run the display system until recently
microsoft sold the whole business to AOL
I don't know what happened then so here
is some reason see buyers will be a
little you know so the you know their
biases introduced through the
consumption rates so as I said earlier I
track the eczema it tries to keep the
rate of consumption and the straight
line in so the straight line you can
give it any curve and it tries to track
to that curve still assume that last
year for so that so the algorithm it's
not part of the algorithm the way to
think of it is it's part of how you
estimate this the sea 80s so however you
do it if there are biases in that their
biases in
tonight so it's it's kind of modular so
you don't have an agnostic algorithm
that if it's what you could learn like
if you know if it doesn't say something
fairly fast you would hope that you
could chart so you're proposing a
different model that is not what this
model is and people have tried to do
those kind of things not tak successful
I want to go back to a theory a little
bit when people saw our algorithm or
even the earlier the MACV algorithm
because it is you know doing this
multiplicative update of the duels
everybody said oh it's related to this
multiplicative update algorithm that's
used to solve the experts problem but
until very recently we didn't have any
formal connection by the way if you
don't know what the experts problem is
it's one of the most celebrated most
used problems in machine learning
machine learning their audit what it
says is okay there are you know it's
also an online problem in every round
the algorithm has to pick one out of n
experts and after you know think of this
stock picks you have to follow one of
the experts and after you've picked you
see the reward of each expert and then
and then you can kind of change your
strategy and pick a different expert and
these algorithms I have this kind of a
guarantee that the reward of the
algorithm is almost as good as the
reward of the best expert on hindsight
so there is exactly not no regret there
is some regret but there it is small and
what we showed was that it's not
necessarily this multiplicative update
algorithm or anything we could use a
black box access to an algorithm that
solves expert so any algorithm you
design to solve this we could use it as
a black box to solve the online budget
allocation or any of these packing
problems so how does it work the experts
algorithm has to pick some probability
so usually the experts algorithm is
randomized so it has a probability of
picking each expert and we take these
probabilities and we normalize it and we
get the dual variables so our
advertisers map to experts and then now
I have to run the expression algorithm
so I need rewards right what what a
reward reverse an expert Scott and the
rewards are essentially this it's this
actual spend minus the ideal spent it so
that's the reward I feedback and then
you know this loop continues and you
know again this should look familiar to
the algorithm what we saw earlier if you
actually use
multiplicative weight update algorithm
for the experts then the algorithm I
showed earlier this is exactly what you
would get so it's related in that way so
what is to you whatever so T is the
total number of impressions of query
static on yet so this is the you know
this is that lay that line the slope of
that line that you spend you know into
the concentrate so practice there is no
fee so in fact ok so this you would
replace it with CA T so I am just
showing it for the IAD case so you
replaced in cata so this is the ideal
spent so you take the actual spin-
ideals
so finally it so we showed that we know
this kind of a algorithm gets the same
optimal convergence rate and what more
using this perspective we could solve
more problems so I said the the problem
i showed the displayer allocation
problem is very close to the actual
problem but there are always some gaps
for instance so because this is
guaranteed delivery it's related to the
question you asked there are hundred
delivery penalties so that is why I just
put a less than equal to so you should
tell you what less there is a penalty
and the way you incorporate this is that
penalty goes into the objective function
except that penalty is non-linear and
the problems you could solve earlier we
are all linear so it was really kind of
cheated some hack to incorporate this
nonlinear into that framework earlier
but now with this new algorithm we can
solve this non linear objective
functions other examples are addresses
they require this mixture of impressions
even though so they may say okay you
know everyone is fine but I want equal
number of men and women or maybe I won't
lose to equal I want equal spread of
different kind of geographical locations
and so on and you have typically
different objectives you have revenue
you have relevance and you have other
things and okay one thing to do is just
combined them linearly it's fine you get
a linear objective but you might want to
combine them in a nonlinear way for
various reasons so all these can be
modeled as either a concave objective
function or as a convex constraint and
this new algorithm it uses no regret
learning can solve all of this so Kim
Sol you know the problems we can solve
in theory are much closer to what a
current practice now
many other generalizations yeah what's
the online learning algorithm which
leads to so it's a black box so it's it
so now you need online convex
optimization if you go back to the
original problem and take the winner is
you know what so the inner haze is not
on Turkish it's the other one the third
one that is talked about with you know
the continuous learning algorithm so
that corresponds to really the
multiplicative update 11 and people have
considered many other generalizations
this is a biased sample of the kind of
things people have looked at when you
show when you show multiple ads on the
page you have common little
combinatorial constraints for instance
you cannot show both pepsi and coke ad
on the same page at the same time people
have considered this there have been
many attempts to mix worst-case
guarantee science to casting coyotes new
kind of maybe like what you were
suggesting and people have considered
like for instance I mentioned there are
multiple objectives and you know one way
to do is just combined them into one
objective but you might want
simultaneous guarantees for each of the
subjective so people have considered
that also and then there is game theory
right so initially we got rid of game
theory but for a lot of these auctions
like search options are options even
display adoptions that are sold on an
exchange each allocation is done via an
auction so the game theory is inherent
and in the rest of the time I want to
talk about how people have tried to
bring game theory back into the soil in
allocation and where we are in that
direction
the first thing I want to talk about
this this thing called a fluid mean
field equilibria I don't understand all
the terms but I have a good idea of what
this means tell you in a minute so think
of display ad exchanges so this is again
display ads but each impression is sold
on an exchange it's sold as a second
price auction now I want to understand
what the the bidders in this oxygen that
have this long-term constraint so they
could have capacity constraints or they
could have budget constraints what Jay
strategies are what they should do and
I'm going to restrict this strategy to a
bit function so what this does is it
takes a value for that impression it
maps to a bid right so this is a
stationary strategy so this does not
depend on how much time is left in the
day or how much budget is left or any
such things it's a station strategy
suppose I fix this such a strategy for
each bidder then now each bidder can
look at all the other bidders and look
at what the competition is this is
called the bid landscape so for every
you know impossible impression you know
what is the highest other bid when I
apply the this bit function and to the
value whatever values computers have so
this gives me some bid landscape okay so
you know it's easy to go from bit
functions to bid landscapes now an
equilibrium is given the bid landscape
this must be a best response for that
addresses so it was maximizes own
utility subject to his budget constraint
right so this is a equilibrium so this
is what is fluid mean field equilibrium
is so this is you know this is a game
between advertisers or bidders and this
is an equilibrium in this game it's not
clear such an equilibrium exists because
I fixed the strategy to be stationary
but actually they showed that such a new
club remixes and this optimal strategy
the equilibrium strategy looks something
familiar something like what we've been
talking you know for the last 30 minutes
it takes a value and integer it is
contract
so a similar kind of a bit lowering
equilibrium in searched actions was also
no proposed by ionic and co-authors
which is one example of the kind of
analysis that people have done trying to
understand the game cynic aspects
so we did a similar thing for search ads
now in such as the default contract is
that you cannot change the bids the bits
are what they are so if you have the
advertiser participate in an auction you
have to use a bit he gave you cannot
change so this kind of a bit lowering is
by default unless um I'd rather allows
you to change the speed you cannot do it
so all you can do as a search engine is
you can take that dress is selectively
out of the auction and you want to do
the sex you know essentially because you
have to do the budget management if you
just put him in on all the auctions and
he will exhaust this budget too soon and
you will not be happy this is called
throttling okay so now the question is
which actions should you put him in
which option should take him out off and
here again you can think of this as a
game between the advertisers now the
strategies are not bits the study is a
bits of some of our kind of fixed the
strategies are whether he wants to be in
the auction or not and here if you look
at threshold strategies so what this
means is every a dresser has a threshold
theta a and he will participate in the
auction if and only if is ROI the return
on investment which is the ratio of his
value to the price he pays is at least
this threshold actually it's not clear
that this is even well defined what we
show is if you fix the thresholds up
front then there is a way for every
option to kind of find a subset of
addresses so I set everyone satisfies
this ritual property simultaneously so
this is not trivial it needs some work
but this racial strategies are well
defined and then again you do the same
thing so once you fix these strategies
you get some sense of what the
competition is because you apply this to
everyone and then you see the
competition and now this must be a best
response given the competition so it is
a very similar idea again so this is a
notion of equilibrium for this game
between advertisers and what we show is
equilibrium exists and we also propose
some heuristics using
essentially the same kind of update rule
that we use for the the continuous
learning algorithm like the
multiplicative update and this seems to
do well in in practice with run
experiments it converges fast but still
for this we do not know in theory we
cannot prove if it actually converges to
Nick loopin so these two are examples
where we are fixing the way an
individual impression or a query is
allocated using an auction like you know
using either the second price of the GSP
auction but you can also consider the
end-to-end problem as one mechanism
design problem with dynamic or online
mechanism design problem but it's
slightly different from the usual type
of making some dynamic mixes and same
problem studied but here so the
advertisers are all present the bidders
are all present in the beginning they
submit their type the entire type is
submitted at the beginning so there is
no extensive form game on anything so it
is a direct revelation mechanism so it
is not dynamic in that sense what is
dynamic or online is a supply so you
don't know what you can sell the supply
is coming online you have to allocate
the items as and when they come and you
may charge a payment at the end or you
may ask the payment also to be charged
online both models have been considered
and there are multiple papers that have
looked at a single item but there are
multiple copies of this item you do not
know how many copies are going to come
but as a copy comes out to allocate it
immediately if you want to maximize
welfare it's actually very easy if you
can charge at the end because you can
implement the VCG but if you want to
maximize welfare while charging also
immediately then there is this paper
that showed how to get a login
approximation and you can't do anything
better than log log n if you want to
maximize revenue then you really need to
charge at the end and you can get a
constant approximation this is other
example where you have budget
constraints if you have additive
evaluations you can
as many items as you want but you don't
want to pay more than certain amount and
in this case in the offline setting
there is this nice pareto-optimal
auction that generalizes Isobel's
adaptive clinching auction and this guy
showed that actually you can implement
this online even when you do not know
the supply so you know allocate and
charge payments online so all this was
for a single item now what happens if
you have two items so suppose there are
two bidders there are two items so they
will submit the bits for both the items
out of time item one arrives always we
are going to get item one you have to
allocate it to someone and then item two
may or may not arrive you do not know so
you have to allocate item one without
knowing whether item 2 is going to come
or not but the payment you can charge
later when you figure out whether item 2
came or not and you want to maximize
welfare now what approximation you can
get if you insist on a truthful auction
the truthful I mean you have to be
truthful in dominant strategy no matter
what
and X a deterministic mechanism any
guesses just two items
you cannot get any bounded factor even
for this case even for this very kind of
the only uncertainty is whether the item
2 comes or not no truthful mechanism can
get any bounded factor just two items to
bidders capacity constraint to the
diversion it better subunit demand sorry
yeah each Peter wants only one item so
you might think okay you know you can
get n N squared e to the n 0 here there
is no n right it's just a you know fix
it sighs you say you cannot get any
approximation just like you is very
surprising it in deters randomized
algorithm can get factor n young
Canadian factor too but if you insist on
deterministic then you cannot get any
finite approximation and the reason for
that is if you also insist that you
always allocate both items you cannot
throw it on something which is a
reasonable thing to expect actually if
you insist on this then there is no
truthful mechanism period and if you do
not insist on this then the truthfulness
constrained what it imposes is that it
makes you throw away items even then the
items are very high value and because of
that you get an unbounded factor and so
this is a joint work with second isn't
see one we just uploaded this paper in
archive last week so if you're
interested in take a look
so to summarize in the non game
theoretic setting where you have a pure
online optimization problem we
understand very well what to do you know
we have this thing of dual based
allocations you know give it to the
highest discounted bidder we know how to
learn this duels from history and how to
update these tools as you go along and
this have been very successfully used in
practice when it comes to incorporating
the game theoretic part then one thing
that people have done to some degree of
success is you fix the auction format
and you try to understand the
equilibrium in the game between the
advertisers there are these two
strategies either you lower the bits or
you throttle them out but if you insist
on a truthful mechanism end to end then
you run into very strong impossibility
very fast but even then i want to say
there is a very interesting open problem
of whether you can get any truthful
mechanism that is asymptotically optimal
in some stochastic settings what are the
suitable assumptions that allow you to
get something that's asymptotically
optimal and such a positive result would
have you know great practical value to
that I want to end thank
in your example so if you change to a
patient perspective I mean the last an
infinite infinite there you go yeah so
so even Batian it potentially we could
do what we do not know any finite
approximation even the patient case no I
know it's fine it's still okay so
randomized mechanisms so what this shows
is you need some sorts of randomization
either the mechanism must be randomized
or the values must be randomized or the
input must be randomized so you if you
know now that there are three directions
you can take this all three of them are
interesting for randomized mechanisms we
know a minimum of M comma n where m is
the number of items and n is number of
artisans we do not know anything better
this is terrible so when I mean by
patient you said if you do so for the
optimal patient mechanism it may not be
you know very good in the worst case but
then you can do it in a truthful way so
patient if you so even patient if you
want it to be truthful in the online
sense that you want it to be truthful
when only item one arrives and you want
you to be truthful on when both the item
arrives you know the truthful can be an
expectation over the values but in the
item arrival it has to be always
truthful we do not know anything so that
is so this this is three interesting
directions here the Batian the
randomized and when the input is no in
stochastic any of these three notion you
know sources of randomness could help we
don't know how much it helps
in the in the algorithmic settings of
the first half of your talk any models
of people that work with where the value
of let's say a plate depends on the
price that I'm paying because as Optimus
worried that that if I did a low number
then I only buy the stuff that nobody
else wants to buy and if I submit high
in bed so I also get some high-value
things and of all the models I see
ignore this and ignore the value per
click is independent of the price of the
yes so this is like the common value
entry dependent values attain
independent value may be quality varies
kisses earth this is people as yeah
people have studied this in the offline
setting just looking at one auction but
I haven't seen anything that
incorporates this into the online
setting
thanks again